Voiceover:What I want to
attempt to do in this video
is figure out what the
sine of seven pi over 12 is
without using a calculator.
And so let's just
visualize seven pi over 12
in the unit circle.
One side of the angle is going
along the positive x-axis
and then let's see,
if we go straight up, that's pi over two,
which is the same thing as six pi over 12,
so then we essentially just
have another pi over 12
to get right over there.
This is the angle that we're talking about
that is seven pi over 12 radians,
and the sine of it,
by the unit circle definition of sine,
it's the y-coordinate of where this ray
intersects the unit circle.
This is the unit circle,
has radius one
where it intersects the unit.
The y-coordinate is the sine.
Another way to think about it,
it's the length of this
line right over here.
I encourage you to pause
the video right now
and try to think about it on your own.
See if you can use your
powers of trigonometry
to figure out what sine
of seven pi over 12 is
or essentially the length
of this magenta line.
I'm assuming you've given a go at it,
and if you're like me,
your first temptation might have been
just to focus on this
triangle right over here
that I drew for you.
The triangle looks like this.
It looks like this,
where that's what you're
trying to figure out,
this length right over here,
sine of seven pi over 12.
We know the length of
the hypotenuse is one.
It's a radius of the unit circle.
It's a right triangle right over there.
We also know this angle right over here,
which is this angle right over here,
this gets us six pi over 12,
and then we have another pi over 12,
so we know that that is pi over 12,
not pi over 16.
We know that this angle right
over here is pi over 12.
Given this information,
we can figure out this,
or we can at least relate
this side to this other side
using a trig function
relative to this angle.
This is the adjacent side.
The cosine of pi over 12 is going to be
this magenta side over one,
or you could just say it's
equal to this magenta side.
You could say that this
is cosine of pi over 12.
We just figured out that
sine of seven pi over 12
is the same thing as cosine of pi over 12,
but that still doesn't help me.
I don't know offhand what the
cosine of pi over 12 radians is
without using a calculator.
Instead of thinking about it this way,
let's see if we can compose this angle
or if we can decompose it into some angles
for which we do know the sine and cosine.
What angles are those?
Those are the angles in
special right triangles.
For example,
we are very familiar
with 30-60-90 triangles.
30-60-90 triangles look
something like this.
This is my best attempt
at hand drawing it.
Instead of writing 30-degree side,
since we're thinking in radians,
I'll write that as pi over six radians.
The 60-degree side,
I'm going to write that
as pi over three radians,
and of course, this is the right angle.
If the hypotenuse here is one,
then the side opposite the 30-degree side,
or the pi over six radian side,
is going to be half the hypotenuse,
which, in this case is 1/2.
Then the other side that's
opposite the 60-degree side
or the pi over three radian side,
is going to be square root of
three times the shorter side.
It's going to be square
root of three over two.
We've used these types
of triangles in the past
to figure out the sine
or cosine of 30 or 60,
or in this case,
pi over six or pi over three.
We know about pi over
six and pi over three.
We also know about 45-45-90 triangles.
We know that they're
isosceles right triangles.
They look like this,
my best attempt at drawing it.
That one actually doesn't
look that isosceles,
so let me make it a little bit more ...
I don't know.
That looks closer to being
an isosceles right triangle.
We know if the length of
the hypotenuse is one,
and this comes straight
out of Pythagorean theorem,
then the length of each
of the other two sides
are going to be square
root of two over two
times the hypotenuse,
which, in this case, is the
square root of two over two.
Instead of describing
these as 45-degree angles,
we know that's the same
thing as pi over four,
pi over four radians.
If you give me pi over six,
pi over three, pi over four,
I can use these triangles
either using the classic definition,
SOHCAHTOA definitions,
or I could stick them
on the unit circle here
to use the unit circle
definition of trig functions
to figure out what the
sine, cosine, or tangent
of these angles are.
Can I decompose seven pi
over 12 into some combination
of pi over sixes, pi over
threes, or pi over fours?
Think about that.
Let me rewrite pi over six, pi over three,
and pi over four
with a denominator over 12.
Let me write that.
Pi over six is equal to two pi over 12,
pi over three is equal to four pi over 12,
and pi over four is equal
to three pi over 12.
Let's see.
Two plus four is not seven,
two plus three is not seven,
but four plus three is seven.
So I could use this and this.
Four pi over 12 plus three pi over 12
is seven pi over 12.
I could rewrite this.
This is the same thing as
sine of three pi over 12
plus 4 pi over 12,
which, of course, is the same thing,
sine of pi over 4,
I'll do this in another color,
sine of pi over 4 plus ...
let me do this ...
plus pi over three,
Now we can use our angle
addition formula for sine
in order to write this
as the sum of products
of cosines and sines of these angles.
Let's actually do that.
This right over here is
going to be equal to,
this is going to be equal to the sine,
the sine of pi over four times
the cosine of pi over three
plus the other way around,
cosine of pi over four times
the sine of pi over three,
sine of pi over three.
Now we just have to
figure out these things,
and I've already set up
the triangles to do it.
What is sine of pi over four?
Sine of pi over four,
well, let's think about ...
This is pi over four right over here.
Sine is opposite over hypotenuse.
That's just going to be
square root of two over two.
This is square root of two over two,
What is cosine of pi over three?
This is a pi over three
radian angle right over here.
Cosine is adjacent over a hypotenuse.
It's adjacent over a hypotenuse,
so this is going to be 1/2.
What is cosine of pi over four?
Go back to pi over four.
It's adjacent over a hypotenuse.
It's square root of two over two.
It is also square root of two over two,
square root of two over two.
What's sine of pi over three?
Sine is opposite over a hypotenuse,
so square root of three over two over one.
Square root of three
over two divided by one,
which is square root of three over two.
Now we just have to simplify
all of this business.
This is going to be
equal to the sum of this,
or the product, I should say,
is just square root of two over four,
and then plus the product of these.
Let's see.
We could write that as
square root of six over four,
or we could just rewrite
this whole thing as,
and we deserve a little bit
of a drum roll at this point,
this is equivalent to,
let me just scroll over
to the right a little bit.
This is equivalent to square root of two
plus square root of six,
all of that over four.
That's what sine of seven pi over 12 is,
or cosine of pi over 12,
what that is equal to.